okay let's go to our caller from the 8th
1/2 area code who's there from 8 1 2
hello
yeah that's you who's this Indiana ok
what's going on today just wondering
what do you think about Venezuela and do
you think we're gonna do a regime change
war for resources yeah I hope not I mean
I think that maduro's gotta go but I
don't want the u.s. to get involved and
when we get involved it's a disaster
historically it's a disaster you know I
think that the idea of there's a various
kind of simplistic meme floating around
of we're going to go to war to take
their oil if you look into the last 10
years of the relationship between
Venezuela and remember the oil in
Venezuela mostly controlled by the
Venezuelan military which is a little
bit of a different thing than you have
in a lot of countries the relationship
between Venezuelan oil and American oil
companies is one that has been pretty
good for American oil companies so the
idea that the oil companies right now
are aching to go and invade Venezuela
which in the short term could actually
disrupt the status quo that they have
and mostly like I think that that's not
an accurate approach Bolton might say we
want to go and take their oil but that
doesn't mean all the oil companies are
on board but I don't want the u.s. to
get involved I'm from Argentina and I
know firsthand about all of the ways in
which American military involvement in
Latin America has been disastrous
but Maduro is an authoritarian strongman
and anti-democratic I'm against that so
I want him to go but I don't want US
involvement
well right cool okay thank you all right
we'll talk to you later